si je fais bien avec m'amuse qui es
faits se sont penchées sur le berceau de
l'humanité et taylor lors qu'un tranches
chaque été s'est arrêtée mais trésor
plein dr2 et de clips des feuilles sur
un pupitre au territoire et des
planchers s'inscrivent eux les unes
après les autres
côté de farandole la battle observe que
trempettes assez elle s'envole paquet de
jusqu'au 20 septembre le club respecte
répondre buenos aires mais j'attends
simplement sort chaque jour que le
soleil à tence je travaille à parfaire
regard séculaire où la prostate vendeur
et je dis je le dire qu'aucun chien de
traîneau je ne tiens pour ma petite
folie pour le plus grand massacre de
pot-au-feu la cre parfois jetés c'est
clair que je me sens impliqué jusqu'à en
être le serveur ou bien ces études
manager que l'on ne peut guérir et ses
filles si on m'a pris ma culture pour
aider fait rire mais chantillac loi
renforce mon opinion et c'est en fait
que je charge le sillon récolter ses
fruits que je tapais d'un vip auquel
j'additionne sa maman quelques rimes jeu
mais habile jetait sur notre cash
autistes enfin je cherche au sur du vide
il relevé
la boucle de ceinture linguistique 1 je
fais avec ma musique mais aussi la
pression si oui je te jure avec rage
avec ma musique mais j'étais avec ma
musique ma vie j'aurai avec ma musique
novice au centre-ville 130 à falker aux
fils et filles de 6 doha et humaine de
la vie civile
celui des poumons d'abou al qosi revient
pas avec mes mains contre des coupures
peindre sur nuitées jo quand la pression
sur moi exerça chusseau nepad et du
quotidien specif et sa multitude armée
qui fumaient ceux qui sont salis de
querbes métal coben les [ __ ] sharif a
ri que les 102 la bague du silence en
bois pour qu'elle revienne mais change
de peau amplifiées mais le poids
caresser mairie bâche d'un royaume dont
il n'y aura jamais décale dans la
mémoire des sens celui des belotti navy
que martin et la santé des hôpitaux
poète qui parle de saulcy fait lober il
a levé pour sa défense une arme et
hongrois chaque été trackers sont en
dessous de pas du nombre
ce sont des gammes de cgi qui fut la
terreur qui ont su rendre des couleurs
jalouse des notes
serait ce un art à part quoi qu'il en
soit je suis tout prix que dans son
dernier rempart derrière il ya là
fleury de paix vers les 1 dans le désert
partie d'un univers de l'univers dans
lequel je suis en main du brevet stick
je fais avec ma musique magnifique mais
j'ai un plaisir avec un mince écart ici
mais je fais avec moi avec ma musique
mais je fais avec ma fille et moi je
fais ça avec ma musique
ouais j'en fais avec ma musique
musique rappelle elle existe depuis
toujours et chaque jour à 6 chacun de
nos temps sont durs parcours pendant des
siècles comme une épouse qui tel pour le
meilleur et pour le pire elle a pris
loeb soutenait la copa del rio dans
l'autre à son quotidien relate
compassion pour appuyer votre peine et
contrairement à ce que l'on dit le
meilleur
ni de grand froid selon g tout près du
dragon est là elle renvoie vers d'autres
horizons où je rencontre des clés les
crochets de deux proches auraient surgi
la france aux côtés sous talent je
décroche pour un court instant la baie
d'authie par rattrape
j'ai dit que le chagrin pour blake un
doublé l'escapade jeu qui jettent comme
sa masse est devenu l'équipe 1
je viens avec ma musique
on fait refonte eu de contrer par les
vents bat y est je suis le roi fou des
us ouvrent un ton peuple de statut au
moins leur passé glorieux investir car
l'avenir puisque dans des méandres du
tube retirer ce sens auprès des anciens
sur leur cas d'écart active des plus
anciens égyptiens fait les leurs pelles
audio lumière du ciel et leurs joies et
terre elle chante encore dans nos coeurs
hautepierre soufflerait d'apaisement au
fond de nous sans aucun doute un
héritage du soleil il ya 5000 ans leur
peau aujourd'hui dans nos oreilles tu
temps s'écoula leurs sons s'étiolant la
chaleur sur mer 2 va passer rythme
violent ayem retourne vers un équilibre
antique
je fais avec ma musique magnifique mais
je peux faire avec des claviers avec ça
je vais pas
je l'avais
voilà c'est iam en direct dans les rues
du panier bonsoir ouais on va se servir
de ce me collard
la dernière fois qu'on s'est vus c'était
en duplex dans l'émission ces ip c'est
un bon souvenir
un bon souvenir qui a fait du bruit
d'ailleurs ça fait du bruit bon moi je
sais du côté de paris à marseille aussi
à marseille aussi où j'ai surtout chez
nos amis nous on n'a pas trop d'écho
disons officiel quoi donc
en fait on a des échos de la part de nos
amis et il aime bien rigoler ouais
c'était c'était un bon moment
qu'est ce que ça fait de chanter vous
êtes venu quasiment pantoufles là vous
habitez l'a quasiment tranquille alors
ça fait quoi de chanter dans son dans
son élément dans son lieu dans son pays
mais surtout surtout pour le panier qui
est un quartier assez les jeunes à
marseille surtout parce que c'est le
seul peut-être quartier qui offre
l'aspect un as un certain aspect de
villages à l'intérieur d'une ville bon
il peur pour moi pour moi il perd un peu
son âme actuellement parce que la lame
du panier c'est quand même un côté très
populaire et je pense que vouloir forcer
un développement culturel mais forcé qui
n'est pas naturel c'est quelque chose de
nocif pour le panier il ya des trucs qui
se passent maintenant et j'ai
l'impression qu'on a regardé les gens
qui habitent le panier comme des comme
des chiens de faïence quoi comme déjà en
vitrine alors que c'est pas ça le panier
c'est la vie avant tout c'est c'est un
quartier riche méditerranée ça doit
rester ça
je sais pas si ça va vous donner raison
mais moi je vais retourner derrière les
grilles pour faire l'émission donc vous
vous êtes au moins en liberté avant
avant ça